كريستيان التفاصيل قادمة للتو ،
قيل لنا ما لا يقل عن 30 قتيلًا و 100 مصاب ،
لكن يمكنك أن تتخيل أن هذه الأرقام سترتفع
جيدًا ، لقد
اتصلنا للتو برئيس بلدية كراميرتورسك
وقد قدم لنا مزيدًا من التفاصيل بشكل أساسي عن
الأرقام  30 قتيلًا الآن 100
جريح ، لكن كما قلت ، لا بد أن
يرتفع عدد القتلى لأن العديد
منهم في حالة حرجة ، كما
يقول وهم في المستشفى وهم
يحاولون علاجهم ، يقول رئيس البلدية إن
هناك هجومين صاروخيين
وسأقرأ لك ما يقوله عن
المكان بالضبط الذي يقول إنهم كانوا فيه في
غرفة الانتظار المؤقتة في المحطة حيث كان
المئات من الأشخاص ينتظرون
قطار الإخلاء في رأيه ، وهذا
دليل آخر على أن روسيا
تقتل بوحشية
الأوكرانيون المدنيون بهدف واحد فقط
وهو القتل ، لذا دعونا نكون واضحين
جدًا خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين ، كانت هذه المحطة
مركزًا معروفًا لعمليات الإجلاء
من الشرق من دونباس ، إنها محطة رئيسية
منطقة هناك هذه المحطة يعرفها الجميع
يقول العمدة أن حوالي 8000 شخص
يأتون يوميًا إلى تلك المحطة ليتم إجلاؤهم
ويتم إجلاؤهم خلال
الأسبوعين الماضيين اليوم.
لقد رأوا
الصور التي لم نبثها بعد
، وهذا يذكرني جدًا
بالهجمات التي شنتها قذائف الهاون في سراييفو
على السوق حيث قُتل مدنيون عاديون
أثناء قيامهم
بأعمالهم للتو ، والمهم في
هذا هو الخسارة الفادحة  الحياة ،
الهجوم الذي لا هوادة فيه على الناس العاديين ، رجالًا
ونساءً وأطفالًا في كل مرة
يحدث فيها هذا ، فإنه يشدد من تصميم الغرب في
كل مرة يحدث فيها رعب ، مما
دفع الاتحاد الأوروبي ، على سبيل المثال ، إلى فرض
المزيد والمزيد من العقوبات على روسيا.